Congrats on season two I mean I feel
like it's been like a long time coming
what does that wait they're like we were
just saying two years just going we were
doing this two years ago I feel like
it's sort of a credit to David Fincher
for not it's sort of what makes the show
special in a way is that he didn't want
to just make the show immediately
because it went well he waited until he
felt like the scripts were really great
and didn't want to just lean into the
same stuff that we did in the first
season but make the second season a
completely kind of new experience
there's such a I think hunger for from
audiences for true-crime what do you
think it is about true crime that
audiences are so fascinated by I think
it's the unknown I think they have
trouble understanding what motivates men
to commit these horrible crimes and part
of the reason they find mine hunter so
fascinating is because we are the
writers and David and we really try to
explore that the personal histories of
the characters you know the
psychological underpinnings of their
crimes and you know it's like it's like
opening a Pandora's box and looking
inside and seeing things that you know
you can't imagine all right you guys
fans of the true crime genre yourselves
where's that kind of your like mmm I'm
working it I don't want to watch a
little bit I kind of sort of take a
little step back occasionally I'll watch
something like I loved the little girl
the B'nai a little documentary it was
made last year so it was pretty great
but that sort of yeah keep it at work
yeah so Edie Kemper scenes in season 1
were just so fascinating to watch I mean
is there a serial killer that you guys
will focus on this season that you're
just really excited to see for audiences
to see we've been talking a lot about
Charles Manson it's the 50th anniversary
of the tate-labianca murders they were
committed in August of 1969 and here our
show is launching in August of 2019
and of course Manson recently died and
so there's a lot of sort of renewed
interest and of course there's mr. Chan
Tino's film and you know and we benefit
from having a really terrific actor in
that role and it's one of the most
exciting scenes I think in the entire
season well and he also played Manson in
Tarantino's in a small part though he
really he really has a lot more to do as
the character in mind hunter and he
takes full advantage of it
so this season focuses on the Atlanta
murders could you sort of tell people
who aren't familiar with it what that is
and also how familiar were you with the
murders before filming I didn't know
anything about them before least before
I read the scripts and started learning
about them basically in the early 80s I
think it was a total of 29 or 30 young
black young ish some young some young
ish black children were murdered in the
course of about a year and a half and
Wayne Williams was tried I think for two
of the murders but essentially everyone
sort of assumes that he committed a lot
of them and our show explores the
complexity of what was happening in
Atlanta at that time politically asked a
lot of questions about the way that the
case was rolled out the FBI's
involvement the local police according
miles who's one of our writers on the
show could have like a degree in Atlanta
from 1979 to 1982 it's very well
researched and I think it's one of the
great centerpieces of this season of the
show is that the first season was a lot
about interviewing killers and and
trying to figure out ways in which you
could get ahead of them and this season
our characters try and in real time find
what they believe might be a serial
killer and in addition to that you get a
sort of like his the historical context
of what was happening in Atlanta if it's
so last question what state are your
characters and going into season two it
picks up not very long after the first
season ends so it's a pretty kind of
direct is that what you mean I mean just
like you know obviously your character
had a panic attack at the end of season
1 I mean are they sort of a united front
or they kind of how would you not at all
[Laughter]
we were investigated by OPR the Office
of Professional Responsibility and we
don't know what the outcome of that
investigation is going to be you know
Holden has disappeared and bill isn't
sure where he is you know I also accuse
my colleague dr. Carr of potentially
having betrayed the unit you know I mean
and and you know was sent to tape in to
the OPR that compromised you know our
work and so we're all very much at odds
at the beginning of the of the season
but um which I'm not going to be able to
tell you where we are at the well I
think that's it for me thank you so much
guys